season one of jupiter's legacy sets up
many plot threads for future episodes to
explore
in addition to the massive villain
reveal in the season finale
the show also established how hutch
would go to the ends of the earth to
save his father
there's also the question of whether
chloe would ultimately follow in her
parents footsteps
and become the superhero they want her
to embody sadly those questions will
remain up in the air as jupiter's legacy
comic book writer mark miller
announced netflix released the cast from
their contracts
dooming any hopes of a follow-up miller
posted in his original tweet that he
remained hopeful a second season could
materialize at some point
but even if that does happen it will not
be anytime soon
after all netflix has its hands full
with a slew of other projects adapted
from the middleworld brand of comics and
miller even revealed in the tweet that
he had begun working on a live-action
series
based on supercrooks while netflix
hasn't released numbers regarding how
many people watch the superhero series
it didn't do too well with critics
garnering only a 38
rating on the tomato meter it likely
didn't help with the series prospects
despite its average audience score of 72
percent
looking through the various comments
that are poured in from twitter it's
clear the show did a massive form of a
fanbase
and those supporters have let their
opinions known that the show deserves a
second chance
one twitter user noted that there were
still plenty of stories to be told
i'm disappointed that jupiter's legacy
is getting effectively cancelled
it's had a lot of potential from its
source materials that could have been
explored in later seasons
in a search for answers some fans think
it came down to one thing
wigs in apparent jest maybe jess several
users make comments like
jupiter's legacy wouldn't have flopped
if they just gave that dude a better wig
and another added wow jupiter's legacy
is already cancelled solely because the
wigs were so bad
so maybe not just at all within a fan
outcry perhaps netflix could reconsider
the future of jupiter's legacy
probably not but fret not there's more
from the miller verse coming soon the
announcement of a live-action super
crook series is intriguing for a couple
of reasons
for starters in the comic books super
crooks takes place in the same universe
as the events of jupiter's legacy
so theoretically characters and events
from the netflix series
could make their way onto this new show
that instead focuses on the villains
secondly the super crook show miller
mentioned in his tweet
will be a different series from the
anime series also in development
as miller explained note super crooks
will appear first as an anime series
from studio bones later this year
other projects in the pipeline include
american jesus and the magic order
however there haven't been any
announcements regarding release dates as
of this time
anyone wanting more stories explicitly
set in the jupiter's legacy universe
does have a bit of luck miller has
worked on a new comic book series
jupiter's legacy requiem the first book
from the 12 issue series drops on june
16th
and it focuses on chloe hutch and their
children
as they continue trying to make earth
peaceful for now
it's the closest thing fans can get to
some semblance of closure
on the short-lived netflix series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
comic book shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one